[Music]
ever wonder what happens to Disney
Princesses after their movies do they
really get to live a happily ever after
from theories to actual movies Mulan has
many stories that explore her life after
happily ever after don't forget to hit
that notification bell to never miss
another video and be sure to check out
our community section for even more fun
now let's check out Milan's life after
happily ever after Milan's backstory
before we get into the happily ever
after and happily never after theories
let's quickly refresh our memories of
what happened to move on in the first
place contrary to popular belief it was
never confirmed that Mulan was actually
a real person
the popular Disney movie was based on a
Chinese story and adapted or so-called
Disney 5 to fit the standard
happily-ever-after narrative Mulan has
yet to be confirmed to be 100% real but
real or not you have to admit that her
story is still incredibly inspiring and
worth talking about so let's dive into
Milan's background before we predict her
future Mulan story starts when her
elderly and unwell father was meant to
go to war Mulan knew that he was far too
weak for that you shouldn't have to go
there are plenty of young men to fight
for China and in order to save his life
she disguises herself into a man and
goes to war instead of him
it's an incredible act of bravery and of
course a controversial one as very
little was heard about women in the
military around that time of course
Mulan is able to pass as a man but she
needs to work on her military skills her
tiny red dragon friend Lu Shu coaches
her on how to behave like a man at the
same time she also faces training from
her captain Li Shang who really has no
idea Mulan is actually a woman Milan is
able to show impressive determination
and confidence that put her up against
Shan Yu the battle ends up revealing to
everyone that Mulan is actually a woman
Mulan risks everything in order to save
China and ends up succeeding in her
mission of course she does she's Mulan
after all every Disney fan was inspired
by Mulan it's by far one of the most
progressive story
Disney decided to portray and definitely
one of the most motivational ones if you
need extra motivation to work hard just
re-watch Mulan Mulan became a popular
character among mini Disney fans and we
can definitely see why she's totally
inspirational not only is she determined
to show off her skill and put her life
in danger for it she also has one of the
most amazing personalities ever
seriously we should all be more like
Mulan so now that we had a little
refresher course it's time to check out
a few theories that talk about what
happens to move on after the original
Disney movie story we'll check out a
theory and not one but two actual
stories of what Mulan went through after
the original and the first theory is a
happily never after one because let's be
honest sometimes things just don't work
out especially if you look at them from
a realistic point of view and this
artist definitely did that happily never
after pollution theory a very talented
artist called Jeff Hong made pretty
realistic drawings of what Disney
Princesses stories would look like in
the present day he Illustrated his
version of Mulan and honestly this is
pretty sad make sure to search him up if
you want to check out other Disney
Princesses because these pictures are
too real for words
and by the looks of it no long story
doesn't really have a happily ever after
ahead of her to be completely honest we
kind of believe it judging by China's
environmental issues but you should
judge it for yourself
Jeff Hong admitted he doesn't really see
Mulan having a life that's any
difference from a standard Chinese
citizen and one of the reasons behind
that is because of the pollution it's by
far one of the most talked about
environmental issues the country is
facing of course this doesn't only
happen in China and we have a feeling
all princesses would struggle mulan
would definitely be facing some of the
same issues that would undoubtedly have
an impact on her health and well-being
jeff doesn't think her story will end up
being a happy one despite her
inspirational impact we really feel for
her and by the looks of it she really
does look pretty unhappy it's almost as
if she's disappointed by the state of
the country she fought so hard for
imagine seeing your country fall apart
because of pollution after you risked
your life to save it what do you think
with this scenario actually be possible
could move on somehow help
with China's pollution or is this
something that's completely out of
control
there are some things that just can't be
solved by fighting and environmental
issues is one of those things okay this
was just a warm-up don't worry we have a
few more stories to show you but we
should also move on to something a bit
more positive shouldn't we our next
scenario isn't actually a theory it's
the controversial Mulan two animated
movie which never really made it on the
big screen it was since
straight-to-video and to be completely
honest with you it really wasn't
received well you'll find out why but
this is basically how Disney sees Mulan
story progress from the original movie
so we just had to add it to this video
happily ever after Mulan 2 came out in
2004 and really it wasn't well received
seriously but despite that it still
managed to receive a dv/dx nomination
for Best Visual Effects it all starts
with the wedding trap it's pretty
obvious Shang and Mulan we're going to
end up together so are we really
surprised but guess what in the middle
of the wedding prep they both get sent
off on a secret mission this must be
pretty important for the Emperor to want
both of us he knows a wedding team when
he sees this win are they the winning
team desmos reminds you of the very
first spy kids movie story when the
parents get sent back on a mission after
years of not being in service well there
are no kids in this movie but it's kind
of similar let's get back on track so
Mulan and Shang go on this mission and
then try to save China once again
seriously when is China not in danger
when it comes to Milan in this case they
have to travel with princesses who are
on their way to basically marry another
country's men in order to form a
political alliance of course the pair
has no idea this is why the princesses
are travelling with them Mulan and Shang
actually get in the premarital fight as
all couples normally do after they
travel for the first time it really
shows that traveling changes you and
it's totally necessary for when you're
trying to get to know your significant
other but anyways it looks like moo shu
is also against the Mulan and Shang
marriage and he actually becomes some
kind of a villain seriously his shady
acts involve deer alien a carriage with
the princesses who almost end up losing
their live
because of this he's way too
manipulative in the sequel Mushu also
tricks Shang into thinking Mulan is
taking advantage of him at some point
Shang ends up falling from extreme
Heights and everyone thinks he lost his
life seriously there's definitely a
reason why this movie was sent straight
to video
boo lime then focuses on trying to save
the princesses that are still on their
way to their arranged marriage destiny
she finally learns the truth and she's
definitely not happy about this who
would be Mulan as brave and noble as she
is actually volunteers to be one that
marries one of the men after all it's
all about China's alliance with another
country and we all know how much Mulan
wants to save China anyways Shang ends
up surviving his fall and he gets
reunited with Mulan they officially get
married and that's the happily ever
after it took a while to get there
didn't it a bunch of other things
happens in the movie but if we were to
tell you about every single one of them
we'd be here all day and all night
there's a reason why this movie had a
zero percent score on Rotten Tomatoes
and you probably know by now that it
wasn't really well-received but we won't
hold that against it it's still the
representation of what happened after
Mullins
original story once upon a time but
malign didn't only share her happily
ever after' story in Mulan - we also saw
her in human form during Once Upon a
Time she had quite a few moments so
let's recap some of them once upon a
time is a beloved series that offers the
viewers an insight into their fav Disney
characters beyond their Disney originals
basically it brings them back to life
and it brings them in human form
Mulan story begins before the first
curse she's serving in the army of the
Emperor of China afterward she spends a
few months trying to find a huge beast
only to find another woman already
trying to lure it out of hiding the
beast comes out to attack the woman and
Milan helps to save her with her bow and
arrow after they defeat the Beast by
restoring him to his human self it's you
become travelling BFFs removed the
beasts from the situation and that's
pretty much how everyone should meet
their travel BFF isn't it we love that
all of these stories agree that Mulan
wouldn't change her free spirit even
after her amazing accomplishments
she's clearly a traveler and everyone
can see it we really
Etsy Milan settling down at home to take
care of kids no matter what situation
she's the type of person that's always
on the move and always active tons of
other adventures happen to Milan in once
upon a time proving that she stays true
to her character all throughout her
happily ever after Milan also teams up
with Merida as she would because let's
be honest these are the two strongest
female Disney characters we've ever seen
Once Upon a Time definitely shows us
that Milan's life is action-packed at
all times and by the looks of this story
she's not at all worried about her love
life
Shane is basically nowhere to be found
to be honest we always wanted Mulan to
team up with other Disney Princesses and
we all know she'll actually get to do
that in wreck-it Ralph to another Mulan
story we're honestly very lucky that
Mulan is such a popular character we
don't really have to make up theories in
order to imagine what happened to her
after the movie in fact 2020 will be the
year we received move on live-action
movie that will give us a pretty good
example of what Mulan
after happily ever after looks like
seriously this girl is so popular and
we're very proud of her unfortunately we
don't really know a lot of details about
the storyline for the live action movie
but here's what we do know according to
reports aleshenka peering in the movie
wait does that mean that Mulan will be
portrayed as the strong woman that
doesn't need a man sort of she does
indeed have a love interest but we bet
she'll be kicking some serious butt this
story will also have a con artist and a
witch as the main villain and that's
about everything we know about it it's
definitely not much is it but we're just
so excited to vogue it another insight
into what life after the Mulan original
looks like for our fierce spirited
princess what do you think happens to
Milan after the original movie do you
agree with her portrayal of Milan - and
once upon a time or do you have a
different idea come share everything in
the comments Mulan is one of our
favorite princesses but we also know
there are Disney fans out there that are
not so crazy about her what's your
opinion you can seriously let it all out
in the comments section below
we won't judge you for your opinion and
that's it for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
see you next time
[Music]